well,
how are you, cristian casseres greets you with an
informative summary of news now in
spanish a local artist won a
four-year scholarship for his career in an
audi the book won an art contest
organized by the university and the
cosmopolitan the objective of the contest
was focused  in diversity uach
created a piece that i call retractions
inspired by the details of the enormous
dome inside the cosmopolitan
congratulations carlos santana returns to the
house of blues at the mandalay bay
santana had canceled his shows for
health reasons but now he is
back he will start with  his performances
in las vegas' starting on wednesday and it wo
n't be all over until may
tickets are on sale now be
sure to check your mailbox
because kobe 19 tryouts are already
on the way residents requested the
tryouts through the page
federal government internet this kit
includes four tests are free of
cost and we close with the weather
forecast  mpo we will continue with sunny days with
a maximum of 63 degrees for
Tuesday and despite strong winds here
in the valley on Wednesday the temperatures will drop a little
the weekend will be warm and
sunny I am Cristian Cásseres
information consumption of Spanish Kirchner on the day
[Music]